Gather round, boys, girls, and
those who are young at heart!
We've talked a lot before about the wacky,
occasionally wonderful but always weird creations
of the mysterious toymaker Dr. Wondertainment,
and today we're going to do it again. It's time
to crack open the SCP Foundation's toy
chest and see what we can find inside!
Dr. Wondertainment's inventions have been
attracting the attention of the Foundation for
quite some time, and with good reason! Whoever
or whatever the whimsical, talented Dr. is,
there's no one else out there producing quite
as many anomaly objects and marketing them
to children as playthings. These aren't the
toys you'll find in your neighborhood store
or on someone's Amazon wishlist. There's SCP-445,
the Super Paper that comes alive in the form of
whatever you fold it into! SCP-1508, or Mikey the
Chore Buddy, a living cardboard robot designed
to help kids with their chores! There are the
adorable-yet-destructive fire-breathing Dragon
Snails, or SCP-111, or SCP-958, General Beep, who
teaches kids about military history and combat,
and helps them build real working toy weapons!
I could keep taking us through the proverbial
toy factory, but we'd be here all day. Maybe
Dr. Wondertainment's most anomalous trait
is how productive he manages to be!
I can barely send a single email
without three cups of coffee! But anyway...
One of the most well-known Dr. Wondertainment
creations is the Little Misters line,
a series of humanoid playmates with a
variety of different traits. We've covered the
Little Misters here on SCP Explained before,
but let's do a quick refresh just in case.
There's Mr. Chameleon, Mr. Headless, Mr. Laugh,
Mr. Forgetful, Mr. Shapey, Mr. Soap, Mr. Hungry,
Mr. Brass, Mr. Hot, Mr. Life and Mr. Death,
Mr. Fish, Mr. Moon, Mr. Redd, Mr. Money, Mr. Lost,
Mr. Lie, Mr. Mad, Mr. Scary, and Mr. Stripes. Each
of these little misters, from the top hat-wearing
fish to the man who can't remember a thing,
they're each special in their own way. But wait
a minute… Looking at them all lined up like that,
I can't help but feel like I'm missing
something. It seems like a bit of a boy's club,
right? And why let boys have all the fun?
Well, it seems like Dr. Wondertainment thought
the very same thing, because he made a Little
Mister just for the girls! Enter Ms. Sweetie, the
sweetest, pinkest gal around! At first glance, you
might mistake Ms. Sweetie for an ordinary woman,
aside from her naturally pink hair and
eyes. No wig or contact lenses here! But,
like the rest of her fellow Misters, Ms. Sweetie
has more to her than meets the eye. So what lies
beneath that candy-coated, sugary exterior?
To crack open that hard candy shell and
get at the truth inside, we'll have to look
a few years back, to when Ms. Sweetie first
caught the attention of the Foundation!
It all started in a small, unassuming town
tucked away in a valley, flanked on
either side by mountains and thick
forests. It was a peaceful place, if a bit boring.
The worst thing anyone could remember happening in
years was a cheating scandal at the yearly pie
bake-off. Then, ten-year-old Nina went missing.
Her family was terrified, they called the
police right away, but the authorities
insisted that it looked like a classic case
of a little girl running away from home.
After all, she'd taken her backpack, her
favorite toys, some sandwiches and bottles
of water from the fridge. She would come back
home soon, probably later that day, and everyone
would be able to laugh about this by tomorrow.
But tomorrow came, and Nina still didn't return
home. People began to whisper, the way folks in
small towns always talk behind each others' backs.
Was there trouble at home? Nina had seemed like
such a happy girl, so outgoing, leading her troupe
in girl scout cookie sales every year and singing
solos in the school choir. Something must have
been wrong, though. Otherwise, where did she go?
Then, others began to disappear. Tommy Bowers
was last spotted walking home from school. He fell
behind his friends, stopping to tie his shoe. When
they noticed he was no longer with them, and went
back, he was gone. Then, Mikey Paulson vanished on
a camping trip in the nearby forest. His father
left him alone for a second in broad daylight,
just to gather some firewood for later that
evening, and when he called out to his son for
help carrying it, there was no reply. One boy was
catching toads in the creek behind his house when
he disappeared. Another was seemingly snatched
while walking his dog. The dog, unharmed, ran
back home on her own, dragging her leash behind
her as she went. It had started with Nina, but
now no one could be certain if it would stop. The
townspeople began to panic, wondering who would be
next? Who was taking their children? And why?
As it always does in small communities in the
grip of terror, suspicion began to grow. Neighbors
turned on each other, pointing fingers at anyone
who seemed the least bit suspicious. Local police
were baffled by the sudden slew of apparent
kidnappings. Sure, they had a few potential
suspects, an elderly woman that the local
kids claimed was a witch, a school groundskeeper
that just had a generally weird vibe about him,
but none of the leads ever went anywhere. There
was no evidence found at any of the scenes.
Where there were footprints, there was only one
set: the child's, leading off into the woods
until they could no longer be tracked. Tensions
were mounting, and no one could trust anyone
anymore. In a town where people had always left
their doors unlocked, people were boarding up
their windows, pulling their children out of
school, and keeping them home at all hours
of the day. If they didn't, after all,
their child could be the next to vanish.
After a week of nail-biting tension and
looking for threats around every corner,
the town was treated to a shocking surprise. Nina
came home. Casual as you please, her parents saw
her come skipping down the driveway, a little
dirty and clearly exhausted, but cheerful. They
embraced her, weeping, and she hugged them
tight, asking them to please stop crying.
"We didn't know where you were!" Her mother
sobbed. "Didn't know if you were okay, or..."
"I'm fine!" Nina insisted.
"They let you go?" Her father asked.
"What? I just got hungry, and I missed
you, so I came back." Nina explained.
"Who took you?" Her mother asked.
"No one took me, I was visiting my friend." Nina
laughed. Her parents stared at her in shock.
"What...friend?" Her father stammered.
"The pink lady in the woods," Nina said
simply, and then she rushed inside to
grab a snack and say hello to the family cat.
Police came by the house to speak with Nina, and,
after talking in circles about her friend in the
woods, and refusing to say that she was kidnapped,
she agreed to show the officers where this "lady
in the woods" was. Other than her location,
all they could get out of Nina was that the lady
was "pink," she could "do magic," and she had
"lots of friends." They had no way to know for
certain, but they hoped that this mysterious
woman would lead them to the missing boys. So,
that same day, a team of police officers, none
of whom had ever seen more action than a parking
ticket or a teenage vandal spray painting a wall,
set out to recover the kidnapped
children from the lady in the woods.
It wasn't easy to navigate, following the
directions of a child. What exactly did she
mean by "go past the rock shaped like a butt,"
or "look out for those purple flowers I like?"
In spite of their obstacles, though,
they were able to get their bearings.
They realized they were getting close, though
close to what they couldn't quite be sure,
when Officer Rita Flinn stepped on something
that crunched loudly beneath her boot.
"What the..." She lifted her shoe, to find
a piece of bright blue hard candy broken
beneath the sole. Candy, in the middle of the
woods. As they searched the area around them,
the rest of the officers found pieces of the
same candy, in different shapes and colors,
all strangely inviting for candy that they
found on the ground. They couldn't explain
the significance of the candy, but they
knew it meant they were getting close.
They followed the multicolored candy trail, like
Hansel and Gretel tracking their path through
the forest with crumbs of bread. They could
hear footsteps up ahead, coming from a nearby
clearing. Through the trees, the team
of officers could make out a log cabin
that looked like it had been abandoned for quite
some time. As they drew closer to the cabin,
and the sounds of activity inside, several of
the officers suddenly froze in their tracks.
They insisted they be allowed to turn back,
to go home. They couldn't explain why,
but they knew that they needed to leave, that
something did not want them there. Officer Flinn,
the only female officer in the group, scoffed at
her colleagues. She urged them not to be cowards,
and to keep moving. There were children's lives
at stake! This was no time to get cold feet.
Still tentative, but feeling thoroughly shamed,
the rest of the officers followed Rita toward
the cabin. So far, so good. No sign of the missing
boys, but no sign of foul play yet either. Then,
behind her, Flinn heard Officer Simon let
out a groan of pain. She turned and saw him
doubled over, clutching his stomach. Before
anyone could intervene, his knees buckled,
and he fell to the ground, suddenly
unconscious. Flinn ran to check his pulse,
and it was steady, but he wouldn't wake up.
His breath gave off a slightly sweet smell,
and she remembered her great uncle, and a trip
he'd taken to the hospital. Somehow, Officer
Simon had fallen into a diabetic coma, right there
in the woods. Before she had time to think too
hard about it, Officer Paul collapsed in the exact
same way, right before her eyes. All around her,
as they attempted to approach the cabin, Flinn's
fellow officers were dropping like flies.
She turned back to the cabin, and her eyes caught
a shock of pink hair as a woman stepped out. She
made eye contact with Flinn, who took note of
her unusual, vivid pink eyes, and she waved.
"Hi, there! What's your name?" She
called in a syrupy sweet voice.
Officer Flinn drew her weapon.
"Hands where I can see them!"
The pink-haired woman cocked her
head in confusion but complied.
"No need to be so mean!" She
pouted. "It's just us girls!"
But that wasn't entirely true. In the forest
behind the cabin, Officer Flinn could see
humanoid figures, trudging through the trees.
But they weren't human, they were shiny, hard,
and brightly colored. She thought of the candy
she stepped on earlier, and her jaw dropped. As
the candy people approached her, she began
to recognize their faces. The missing boys,
each and every one of them, transformed somehow
into living hard candy. Holding her weapon in
one hand, and keeping an eye on the pink-haired
woman and her tiny candy army all the while,
she pulled out her radio and called in
the strangest report she had ever made.
No one in the town, not even the chief of
police, had ever heard of anything like this.
But fortunately, the police chief knew someone
who did. An old friend who devoted her time
to investigating cases that were impossible to
explain. Less than 24 hours after Officer Flinn
made her call, the SCP Foundation was arriving
at the scene to collect the candy children, and
the woman who would become known as Ms. Sweetie.
Officer Flinn's report, along with an in-depth
study of both the hard candy pieces, and the hard
candy humanoids obtained from the crime scene,
offered some insight into Ms. Sweetie's abilities.
Her presence inherently repels men that come
within 50 yards of her, and any man that enters
her radius will feel an immense desire to leave,
and go back in the opposite direction.
If he is forced to continue his approach,
then he will begin to feel ill,
experiencing nausea, shortness of breath,
and severe stomach pain. Finally, he will fall
into what resembles a spontaneous diabetic coma.
The only way for him to regain consciousness is
to be brought back outside of the 50-yard radius.
As for the hard candy, Foundation researchers
gave one piece to a female D-Class,
and another piece to a male D-class, to test
the effect it might have on different genders.
When the woman ate her piece, she simply chewed,
swallowed, and looked at the attending researcher
in confusion, as if to say, "Was that it?"
When the man ate his piece, however,
his body began to undergo a rapid transformation.
His blood sugar levels skyrocketed, rendering him
immobile almost immediately. Over the next twelve
hours, his flesh, bones, musculature, and all
other parts of his body began to crystallize into
hard candy. When the transformation was complete,
the new entity attempted to free Ms. Sweetie
from her containment. He was neutralized using
a flamethrower, which melted the sugar
of his body down into a sticky puddle.
Any person identifying as a male who eats
a piece of this hard candy will experience
a similar effect, just as the missing
boys did. In some, very rare cases,
the transformed party will turn into a candy
unicorn, rather than a humanoid creature,
but the cause of these special cases is unknown.
After Ms. Sweetie was brought into Foundation
custody, and given her official designation of
SCP-2396, specialized containment procedures
were put in place to keep her in captivity.
She was placed in Provisional Site 2396, and,
due to her distaste for men and boys, assigned a
research staff that consisted entirely of women.
Any men or masculine-identifying individuals
located within a 6 km radius of the site were
to be temporarily detained and questioned
about any possible contact with SCP-2396.
So every night in Provisional Site 2396 was
Ladies' Night! But it wasn't much of a party.
Researchers were preoccupied with finding a way
to neutralize SCP-2396's anomalous effects. Most
notably, in spite of her containment, small pieces
of assorted hard candy - or SCP-2396-A - would be
spontaneously generated within a 6-kilometer
radius of Ms. Sweetie. Any of these that were
spotted would be incinerated on sight, but the
Mobile Task Force in charge of supervising the
area was having trouble keeping up. Male civilians
were slipping through the cracks, eating the
candy, and transforming into candy humanoids, or
instances of SCP-2396-B, then storming the Site
and attempting to free Ms. Sweetie from captivity.
It was becoming untenable to keep her contained.
The generation of instances of SCP-2396-A was
directly connected to her regular consumption
of sugar in all of its forms, which she
requested as rations. The amount did not matter,
nor did the form it took. She merely required
something sweet once a day. Sometimes it was a
bowl of pure cane sugar, sometimes a cup of
maple syrup. On a staff member's birthday,
they brought her a piece of chocolate cake,
which she was especially delighted by.
Eventually, they settled on a single liter of
glucose syrup once a day, hoping it could slow
things down by eliminating any whimsy or variation
from the feedings. Every time, without fail,
more instances of the anomalous candy would
manifest soon after SCP-2396 ate her meal.
There was talk of starving her, to see if
this could mitigate the generation of candies,
but when denied sugary foods, Ms. Sweetie would
double over in pain, wailing about the agony she
felt. The head researcher at the Provisional
Site was horrified by the notion of torturing
an anomaly that had done no intentional harm
to anyone, and insisted they find another way.
One researcher, Dr. O'Herlihy, proposed a
solution: why not try a sugar substitute?
They decided to test it out, giving SCP-2396
a liter of liquid sucralose, while behaving
as though it was her ordinary dose of sugar. She
accepted it graciously and made no complaints of
pain at all. After switching to the sucralose,
the candy stopped appearing. Ms. Sweetie was
reclassified as Euclid, and moved to Site-19.
After a week of the sucralose-based containment
procedures, Dr. O'Herlihy conducted her fifth
interview with SCP-2396. For the sake of avoiding
any potential outbursts, Ms. Sweetie was led
to believe that she was still producing candy
as well as living candy creatures. A transcript
of this interview is included in SCP-2396's
official file. Dr. O'Herlihy sat down at
the table, where Ms. Sweetie was already
waiting with a pleasant smile on her face.
"Good morning, SCP-2396." Dr. O'Herlihy began.
Ms. Sweetie scoffed and giggled at this opener.
"Oh, come on, Cindy! You don't have
to be all stuffy with your best gal!"
Dr. O'Herlihy responded with a polite smile,
neglecting to correct SCP-2396 on the fact
that Cindy was not, in fact, her first name.
"Alright, SCP-2396, are you aware another
SCP-2396-B attempted to breach your containment?"
She referred, here, to one of
Ms. Sweetie's candy soldiers.
Ms. Sweetie giggled. "That's just boys. Always
gotta be makin' a big stink of things when they
wanna get your attention. Ain't it always like
that? Never a man, always a boy. Always beatin'
up their friends when they think they're gettin'
too close. A man's always gotta have his hands
busy or else they're gonna be in the air."
Dr. O'Herlihy pressed the matter, "They
seem to be concentrating on taking you away
from here. Are you unhappy here, SCP-2396?"
Ms. Sweetie sighed. "A woman ain't happy
anywhere. Isn't that what they say?"
Dr. O'Herlihy frowned. "I am
not aware of any such saying."
Ms. Sweetie shrugged. "It should be one. I
don't know, Lucy, I think it's just because
every gal wants a big strong lug to sweep
her off her feet, and these are sweet boys,
deep down. Even if they're sticky. I'm sure they'd
sweep you off your feet, too, if you girls asked."
Dr. O'Herlihy thought about commenting on
the inherent sexism and heternormativity of
this statement, but thought better of it. She also
considered pointing out that Lucy was not her name
either, but shook it off.
"Then what about the
instances that resemble unicorns?"
Ms. Sweetie lit up at the mention of these.
"Don't you just love unicorns? All little
girls love unicorns. You can eat them, too,
when you get bored. Little girls get bored.
It's good to have boys and unicorns you can
eat when you're finished."
"Isn't that a little
reductive?" Dr. O'Herlihy replied.
Ms. Sweetie appeared to become irritated. She
rolled her eyes. "Look, toots. I'm a girls' toy,
and it's a man's world. What do you want from me?"
"Is that why you repel men?
Because you're a girls' toy?"
Ms. Sweetie nodded. "Dr. W didn't like
it when boys break their sisters' toys.
Told me it was damn near the worst thing
in the world. And they can't break me.
They can't even come near me. Well, 'cept if
they're, you know, all sweet and handsome."
"And you're happy with the way
things are?" Dr. O'Herlihy asked.
Ms. Sweetie paused for a moment to consider,
then answered, "Dr. W's good in my book. I
always had a sweet tooth, and I always wanted to
be a girl. Kind of an okay trade-off, if you ask
me. You guys ain't so bad, though. Even if the
food's crap. Don't know how you mess up sugar,
Sarah, but you guys make it taste like crap."
Aside from complaining about its taste, and no
longer being able to produce any of her anomalous
candy, the sucralose substitute has had no adverse
effects on SCP-2396. At this point in time, no
containment measures beyond this dietary change,
and making sure all staff that interact with
her identify as women, have been necessary.
So, Ms. Sweetie sits in her cell in
the low-security wing of Site-19,
missing her favorite sugary treats, but otherwise
content with the way things are. And on the
outside, no more unsuspecting boys are being
transformed into confectionary against their will.
Just to be safe, though, if
you're ever out walking and
you see pieces of delicious-looking
hard candy scattered along the ground,
just remember what your parents always
said: Don't take candy from strangers.
You just never know where it came from.
Now go check out "SCP-001 - A Simple Toymaker"
and "ALL the Little Misters Explained" for more
on the mysterious creations of Dr. Wondertainment!